[Music]
while therefore the noble consciousness
behaves as if it were conforming to the
universal power the truth about it is
rather than in its service it retains
its own being for itself in that in the
genuine renunciation of its personality
it actually sets aside and rends and
pieces the universal substance it's
spirit is a completely disparate
relationship on the one hand in its
position of Honor it retains its own
will on the other hand it gives up its
will but in so doing in part alienates
itself from its own inner nature and
becomes utterly at variance with itself
and in part subjects to itself the
universal substance and makes it
completely at variance with itself it is
clear that as a result the specific
character which it was judged to have in
comparison with what was called the
ignoble consciousness has disappeared
and with the latter to this the ignoble
consciousness has achieved its purpose
that is to bring the universal power
under the control of being for self
paragraph 513 is relatively short but
there is a lot going on in it this is an
important transition point where we see
Hegel at the very end of it saying that
the ignoble consciousness or literally
the the dragging down consciousness they
neither tactic before Stein has achieved
its purpose its Zach its aim its goal to
bring the universal power under the
control of being for self so what we're
gonna see here now is a return from
talking all about the the state power
noble consciousness not talking about
wealth more and also talking about what
happens with the ignoble consciousness
because you know when we're talking
about culture a little bit of a side
note you know we generally think of
culture especially ancient culture and
medieval culture in terms of what it is
that we get to see and a lot of that has
to do with these these relations of
fealty loyalty you know honor all
obedience right service but there's
always this other stuff going on in the
background and Hegel is very attuned to
that because that's equally as real if
not always as effective so Hegel tells
us that there's now a fundamental split
within the noble consciousness so he he
describes it here in this passage as a
completely disparate relationship in
terms of its spirit right so he says the
noble consciousness behaves as if it
were conforming to the universal power
all right it were it was actually
adjusting itself it was finding its
meaning there but the truth about it he
says is rather that in its service it
still retains its own being for self and
and we saw this discussed at a number of
points earlier in this section there is
a fundamental reserve that that's being
held back the the the individual as
individual cannot
throw him or herself entirely into
obedience and service to the the greater
Universal because if they do theirs well
there's nothing left there's no
individual the sacrifice becomes silent
we saw that there's a transition in
language to flattery to a different kind
of service that creates the not talked
about here in this passage but lurking
in the background the unlimited monarch
so what's happening here with the noble
consciousness he says the truth about it
is that in its service it retains its
own being herself and that in the
genuine renunciation of its personality
so it's not such as being self-serving
this is Hegel saying that even when you
do try to totally renounce your own
personality to sacrifice yourself you're
not completely succeeding in it there's
still a little bit of the self behind
it's almost reminiscent of Kant's
discussion in the groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals where he says the
most you know disinterested from duty
action you can never really be totally
sure that there isn't a little bit of
self-love lurking in the background
motivating you to do it Hegel saying
something like this here except in a
broader sense because of course his
ethics is not a purely formal one like
can't hear the ethical means serving the
state power doing what it is
substantively that it requires in those
circumstances and yet there's a little
bit of oneself held back so he goes on
and he says on the one hand in its
position of honor it retains its own
will this is what it means for it to
hold something back on the other hand it
gives up its will now notice what he
says next
in doing so it alienates itself from its
own in turn Eicher and becomes utterly
at variance with itself we have not only
a tension here we have really a
contradiction and
antithesis in the strongest sense of the
term an opposition within the very heart
of the person and this is why the noble
consciousness can vacillate back and
forth not vacillating about whether it
should act or not it is acting it is
sacrificing it is doing service but
vacillate about whether that is truly
self-motivated you know which it doesn't
want it to be or motivated towards the
greater good of the whole of the
universal it questions its own motives
why does it question its own motives
because its own motives remain
questionable and it knows that there's
still something of its own will held
back it can sacrifice that over and over
again Hegel talks about this in a very
punctual way but we might think about
this vacillation that's going back and
forth as occurring over and over again
where a person recommit s' themself and
says alright I found this little reserve
of myself I'm going to also devote this
I'm going to devote this I'm going to
devote this this not only happens in
terms of say a political community and
its ruler but also in terms of you know
religious traditions and philosophical
traditions where the care of the soul is
the object you find a little bit more of
self love in the bad sense sacrifice
that but you're still going to find some
residue of that and the question is do
you ever reach a point where you start
to say well I'm not gonna get rid of
this as a matter of fact I ought to hold
something back for myself I ought to
think not just about the the sovereign
and the society but but about my own
self or about those closer to me so he
goes on and he says we've got an
alienated itself from its own inner
nature right and he says it imparts
subjects to itself the universal
substance and it makes the universal
substance at odds in variance with
itself right the unlimited monarch in a
certain sense can become a
closed to the general good of the state
and this is indeed what we see happening
over and over again civilization after
civilization that goes through this
dynamic you pool your power not only you
know arms and economics but what we
might call cultural power the power of
attention the power of language into the
the monarch and the monarch discovers
that he or she really is in charge this
is where character gets tested the most
and often is found failing isn't it and
these can be at odds with each other and
we see societies go through this sort of
process where they they have to sort
this out and they realize that there is
a contradiction so you know the British
found an issue and it led to a
revolution the French likewise later on
found themselves deposing their monarchy
their absolute monarchy other countries
went through a more constitutional
process right we even see this as a
problem recurring today the kind of
variance between the general good of the
state and the more and more unlimited
powers of the ruler whether we're
looking at you know totalitarian
societies in which there definitely is a
cult of personality or whether we're
looking at liberal democracies which
have a very strong figure in charge if
you think about our current you know
presidency and the fact that over really
the last 40 years or so
executive power has been growing and
growing and growing in relation to the
legislative and judicial powers and how
many you know affordances over not only
economics but life and death have been
given to the person who happens to
occupy that spot for four or eight years
we might see a similar antithesis going
on as well but returning to what Hegel
is talking about here in this historical
development he says
we reach a transition point it's clear
he says that as a result the specific
character which it was judged to have
what's it the noble consciousness in
comparison with what was called the
ignoble consciousness has disappeared so
what do we mean by saying it's
disappeared the specific character what
was distinguishing the noble
consciousness from the ignoble
consciousness was this service right
this taking on whatever came to it and
saying okay to it and not holding
something back because it is holding
something back so what is this saying
everybody everybody across the board is
holding something back is behaving in a
somewhat self-centered way we can say
well that changes things so now we can
no longer distinguish between the noble
and the ignoble consciousness but Hegel
goes further he tells us that with this
not only has the the the distinction
disappeared the latter the ignoble
consciousness has also disappeared maybe
the ignoble consciousness is not as
ignoble as we had thought and we reached
the point now where again he says the
ignoble consciousness has achieved its
purpose how is it achieved its purpose
was it behind the scenes you know
messing around oh I'm gonna set this up
so that you know this this dynamic plays
itself out no and Hegel doesn't think it
works like that
but the ignoble consciousness now has
managed to reappear in history as not
being quite so ignoble as perhaps
serving some sorts of glitz even though
it's self centered so how is it done
this it has managed to bring the
universal power he says under the
control of being herself being for self
in terms of the unlimited monarch or
being for self in terms of the noble
consciousness now consciousness
self consciousness thus enriched by the
universal power exists as universal
beneficence or as wealth which is itself
in turn an object for consciousness for
although wealth is for consciousness
into the depot's universal the latter
has not yet by this first objection
returned absolutely into the self the
self has not yet for object itself qua
self but the subordinated universal
essence since this object has only just
come into being consciousness has formed
an immediate relation with it and thus
has not yet exhibited its disparity with
it we have here the noble consciousness
which preserves its being for self in
the universal which has become uh
nacelle and therefore acknowledges the
object it is grateful to the benefactor
paragraph 514 is another short paragraph
but but I think a very difficult one for
people to wrap their heads around and
figure out exactly what's going on here
so there's a tendency when you're
reading Hegel to sort of pass over those
and think that I don't make itself clear
in the end I'll come back to it later
but we really do want to concentrate
here on what what Hegel is saying so we
can try to make sense of it and so he's
talking here with a few different terms
there's there's self-consciousness and
wealth right that are coming into the
fore and I think we want to be careful
in distinguishing well what aspect or
what shape of self-consciousness are we
talking about here because ultimately
we're gonna hear him talking about the
noble consciousness which is undergoing
this important transformation at this
point so he says self consciousness thus
enriched by the universal power how is
self consciousness enriched by the
universal power right that's that's
where we should stop and ask so do we
mean in a sort of metaphysical sense do
we mean in a cultural sense it's been a
coordinate kind of importance do we mean
very literally that the universal power
is not just giving it honor but giving
it money what was the universal power it
was that of the state but now the
universal power is turning out to be
wealth and remember that when Hegel
talks about wealth he doesn't just mean
money in the bank or gold or you know
lands or things like that he it has in
mind a much more active dynamic
conception of wealth as circulating as
operating through exchange as something
that you can't quite pin down Hegel was
conscious of you know the development of
political economy but he he's not
attempting to provide you with a
political economy at this point rather
he's talking about wealth in the sense
that he means as something like a social
force so he says
enriched by the universal power self
consciousness exists as universal
beneficence and now this is another
interesting aspect of wealth right if
you have wealth one of the peculiar
things about it is that you can bestow
it on somebody else you can share it
with somebody else and it could be real
property right hey come and live on my
land or take this clothing but it could
also be creating the very opportunity I
mean I don't think Hegel has in mind
you know microlending or anything like
that but that wouldn't be so far from
what we're talking about here the the
creation of opportunities for agency for
her enjoyment for generating something
that then goes on to other people so
Hegel says that this is wealth right
self-consciousness he says exists as
Universal benefits or it is wealth which
is in turn which is itself in turn an
object for consciousness so it is wealth
and at the same time in that being that
wealth is an object a gig and stand for
consciousness it is something that
consciousness can think and
behind-the-scenes here is the
possibility of alienation you are not
just your wealth but your wealth is you
in a certain respect because it has to
do with what you can do how that we can
show beneficence and yet it's detachable
from you we could go on and on these
these sorts of points but he says
although wealth is here we get start to
give very metaphysical for consciousness
the deposed universal remember back to
earlier on in this where we had the two
universals right the universal estate
power and then the universal of wealth
and and wealth ended up going into the
background it was an essence it was the
v's and that which is important which
you know has being but state power was
where all of the development was taking
place now while
is showing back up again says wealth is
that opposed universal but the latter
what is the latter the deposed universal
has not by this first subjection
returned absolutely into the self wealth
isn't quite aware of what wealth is at
this point nor is the self consciousness
that is engaged with wealth fully in the
know about what it is and what this
object is
so wealth is this deposed universal he
also calls it a subordinated Universal a
little bit later he says the self has
not yet for object itself qua self but
instead he has for object the the these
subordinated universal essence right and
just remember a little bit earlier not
just a few paragraphs back Hegel talked
about a will which is subordinated to
other wills here we're talking about
wealth as being a subordinated Universal
essence anybody can use it as they see
fit as they think it ought to be used so
he goes ahead and he says since this
object has only just come into being
consciousness has formed an immediate
relationship with it right an immediate
relation immediate means that it's not
fully understood it's not fully worked
out so he says thus has not yet
exhibited is its disparity with it so
what we have here is the noble
consciousness which preserves its being
for self in the universal which has now
become honest enchilada central
Universal and noble consciousness is
once again being knowable and
identifying itself with it and it's
being for self is now connected with the
wealth Hegel talks here at the end about
gratitude towards the benefactor and and
you know so who is this self
consciousness that is universal
beneficence well that's a question
that's not actually resolved in this
passage is it the absolute monarch I
don't
so although he could certainly if she
can certainly be distilling things
rather it's whoever has the wealth to be
able to bestow the noble consciousness
now finds itself receiving something
different than just honor but there is
still some gratitude he says it
acknowledges the object and it's
grateful to the benefactor so what we
have here is a again an important
transition point that is taking place
within this stage of the dialectic
wealth already contains within it the
moment of being for itself it is not the
selfless Universal of state power or the
naive inorganic nature of spirit in a
state powered which wills to hold its
own against those who would take
possession of it for their own enjoyment
but since wealth is merely the form of
essence this one-sided being for self
which has no intrinsic being of its own
but is rather the cancelling of it is in
its enjoyment the essence less return of
the individual into himself
it therefore itself requires to be in
sold and the movement of its reflection
consists in this that wealth which it is
only for itself develops an intrinsic
being of its own then instead of being a
canceled essence it develops an
essential being if thus receives within
itself a spirit of its own
since the form of this movement has
already been set forth in detail it is
sufficient here to characterize its
content
paragraph 515 is a fascinating passage
and there are a few you might not say
outright mistakes but but in Felicity's
of translation here in the Miller text
that I do want to call your attention to
because you could get the wrong
impression about what's going on and not
see how important the transition that's
being described actually is
so he says wealth contains within at the
moment of being for self right and he
contrasted here against what he calls
the selfless Universal of state power
and the naive inorganic nature of spirit
he says state power wills to hold its
own against those who would take
possession of it for its own enjoyment
we've already talked about that wealth
doesn't do that wealth will allow itself
to be used by whoever it will
subordinate itself to somebody's will to
their choice to even to their
arbitrariness their Vilakku
right and in doing so it is able to do
something different it's able to offer
something more you might say
so he says wealth has merely the form of
essence right wealth is is Vaes in' and
we've talked about this quite a bit now
here's where it gets particularly
interesting he says since wealth has
merely the form of essence this
one-sided being for self which has no
intrinsic being of its own it has sign
and physique but not design on Zeke
right being in itself intrinsic being he
says it's rather the cancelling of it
and here is where I want to call
attention to the the German right so
this this cancelling is actually elf
fable that's a very important term right
it never means merely cancelling merely
negating merely getting rid of there's
always a transition and an integration
into something higher right in the
Hegelian dialectic so he says it's the
cancelling of it right of this be
points off of this one-sided being for
self and he says that in its is it is in
its enjoyment the essence less return of
the individual into himself so it sounds
as if look wealth when it's just the
individual using wealth as kind of a
means to attain the satisfaction that
they want or to to buy something
necessary for life or any of that sort
of stuff wealth doesn't really have its
full meaning its its meaning you know
its intrinsic being it sits on Zeke
right it has its for itself but notice
that it's for itself is one you might
say a different kind of service than
we've been talking about in all the
paragraphs a and adaptability a
usability now he says wealth he says
therefore itself requires to be insult
in soul meant is translating belay bung
here being given a you know liveliness
we could say right requires being in
sold and the movement of its reflection
consists in this now here again the
translation gets a little wonky the
movement of its reflection consists in
this that wealth which is only for
itself
Thoreau Zeke right develops an intrinsic
being of its own now Hegel doesn't
actually say that it develops merely an
intrinsic being of its own he says that
it develops and on and furs I'm that is
an in and for itself being so both
intrinsic and for itself right bringing
these together not merely shifting from
the for itself to the in itself how is
wealth going to to do that he says
instead of being canceled essence and
again canceled ow hey bong alcohol burn
up right instead of being an alcohol ban
of eizan he says it develops an
essential being no it becomes an essence
if there isn't a difference here between
the canceled or sublated or
transcended essence and the essence that
it becomes this is essence becoming
essence showing what its essence is
revealing itself to us that's what's
happening in this discussion of wealth
according to Hegel so he says it thus
receives within it and here we get a
really interesting a spirit of its own
so it's not merely a tool it's not
merely to pure economics it's not merely
any thing that's merely something this
is part of the development of spirit
self-consciousness and spirit occurs
just as much through wealth as it does
through state power this is an important
result isn't it and Hegel says well now
the form of this movement has already
been set forth in detail I don't know if
you're exactly happy about the detail
but it's been set forth in because Hegel
then says it's sufficient here to
characterize its content so he's going
to go on and talk about this this
ongoing development and dialectic of
wealth but he's not going to tell us
more at this point about just how we
actually got here so again you might say
this is kind of a quick transition isn't
it but hopefully in the passages yet to
come you see that maybe a bit of it
reflects backwards into what's going on
here this really is an important crux
point of this transition that's now been
taking place for several paragraphs
where we're moving to consider well or
Reich to them
you